foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
artist originally from the Imperial
Valley California this is the last show
the Fonda right here in L.A Zeke's
Taqueria that's my crew that's my brand
and it's all based around my dog he's
the owner he runs the whole right I
started off just rapping and that was
the most accessible thing really
inspired by Sublime a whole lot of other
people too right a lot of Mexican music
because that's how my mom would play
the big names like
I like to sing about things I'm going
through right whether it's struggles or
things that I'm happy about my
relationship with my girl or my
relationship even when my dog inspired
me a lot my family I like to get real
nostalgic on a lot of songs and reflect
back on my childhood and things that
shaped me into who I am today if I'm
able to just make music and live off of
that that's all that's all I care about
thank you for listening to my music if
you've never heard of me you know give
it a chance check it out you might like